-Thank you for being here. I
want to talk about the new song.
I know in Brazil, you --
the biggest star, the massive --
I mean, it's insane. You went
platinum. It's crazy. I mean --
-Yeah.
-And how does it differ from
the U.S. and what's happening,
'cause it's happening here now.
-Yeah, I started singing in
English and in Spanish.
Spanish, like, four years ago
and English like one year ago.
And in Brazil I have, like, 12
years of career.
And everything started to grow
up very fast.
But then whenever I got really
big there,
I was like okay next step? I
wanna do something challenging.
And somebody told me that for
Brazilians it was impossible
to break up, like, to break out
of Brazil to cross over.
And whenever I hear the word
"impossible,"
I want to go for it.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You are making history.
I know that you are actually --
you're performing at Coachella.
-Yeah.
-Which is massive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
April 16th and the 23rd.
Great line up, Billie Eilish,
Megan Thee Stallion, 21 Savage.
What can people expect when they
go to see you in Coachella?
-I'm -- I mean, I want to bring
Brazil to the stage
and all of the favelas.
I come from a community --
do you know what a favela is?
-Favela? No.
-Have you ever seen the movie
"City of God?"
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a favela.
We just party really hard.
It's just a different energy,
you know?
Like, whenever --
if ever you come to Brazil,
you've got to bring a
little extra energy maybe.
-You do?
-My friends all like to party.
-So it's going to be wild?
-Yeah, I think so. Yeah.
-I love that. Why not? I think
everyone wants it right now.
Everyone feels like they need
it, come on we need this love.
We need this energy, let's go,
let's have fun.
-Yeah, by the way, I wanted to
ask you something.
I love the puppies here 'cause
this --
the puppy's really smart.
The Cincinnati one, the Bengals.
He's the right one.
I want to bring it home.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You want to take that little --
-'Cause the Bengals
going to win for sure.
I know for a fact.
You can bet all your money
there.
All your money you can bet on
Cincinnati Bengals.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I feel this.
You're in my head right now.
Because I've never taken
financial advice
from you before --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But tonight I feel like
I'm actually going to do it and
put all my money -- honey --
-You know I'm also a director of
a bank in Brazil? I do that.
But do you know how I know I'm
going to win --
they're going to win?
I win together.
'Cause one of my men is playing
there. One of my men is.
-What do you mean?
-'Cause I have in each
different city --
I'm traveling a lot.
-Oh my God. You are -- Anitta --
don't you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Listen.
It's a lot of countries.
I was, yesterday, in Brazil.
Day before, I was in L.A.
I've got to have options.
So, one of my men --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How do you end up
in Cincinnati, okay?
-So I was in a strip club in
Miami and I saw this guy,
he was super hot and I said,
"Yo, if you don't find anyone
to have sex tonight hotter than
I am, you just call me.
And if I don't find anyone
hotter than you, you call me,
I call you, too."
-Wow.
-So, in the end of the day, we
both found.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Is that how? Is that how it
works, is that how it works?
-Well, I'm practical!
Some Brazil energy.
I wouldn't say all Brazilians
are like that but I am.
So, after that I ended up
going to Cincinnati and,
I know they're going to win
because I'm going to make sure
he has a great night before.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to make sure.
-Alright.
You guys heard it first.
There you go.
Peyton Manning didn't say that,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't know anything
about football, I actually
thought it was soccer
because we call soccer football
in Brazil.
-I know. Exactly.
-So I didn't know anything,
I needed to search, but now I
know everything.
He's going to have
a great night,
and he's going to win next day.
You can bet all your money.
-There you go. Right there.
"Boys Don't Cry." It's a jam.
I love it. Everyone loves it.
You're going to perform it for
us later.
You were saying backstage
that this is not
what it started out as,
this song.
It was going to be more of a,
like, a disco type of jam or --
-Yeah, it's more like, when I
was a teenager,
I liked this rock vibe.
This kind of -- you know?
-Yeah.
-And I wanted to
bring this back,
I loved Panic! At The Disco,
so that was my reference for
this song.
-Love Panic! At The Disco.
-Yeah, I love it.
-And it turned into this --
-Yeah, 'cause here's the deal,
I started doing a rhythm in
Brazil.
It suffers a lot of prejudice,
it's funk --
it's kind of like hip hop
in '90s for America.
Suffers a lot of prejudice
because it comes from the ghetto
and the poor people
in the communities.
So, people used to think,
"Oh, she shakes her ass
so she's dumb."
And I wanted to show
a different side.
Like, yeah, I shake my ass,
but I can be smart.
And I can do other rhythms.
You know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Absolutely.
You know what you're doing.
I can sing rock.
-Yeah.
I think you know
what you're doing, buddy.
I really do.
The video, by the way, I loved,
you directed it.
-Yeah.
-Which also I love that
you did that too.
You're like, "Oh, no, I'm not
just going to put a video out.
I'm going to direct it."
-Yeah,
'cause whenever I cut the song,
I had so many ideas
for it.
And I love movies, all my
reference I bring from movies,
because I think it helps me to
not go through
a place that other singers
are going.
So, I just got reference from
movies I love I love,
like, "Runaway Bride,"
"Harry Potter," "Beetlejuice."
-"Beetlejuice"
I love that you did that.
But I mean, all, like,
gorgeous versions of everything
you just mentioned,
but yeah.
-Yeah, that's "Titanic," that's
"Beetlejuice."
But then I do, like, the
ex-boyfriends run away from me
in the other scene because I
have, like 50 ex-boyfriends
and they were all chasing me.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God
-So I wanted to reproduce
my real life.
-Uh...
-I say "Boys Don't Cry"
just in the title,
but in the song they cry
'cause that's how they feel.
-That's right.
That's exactly right.
That's how they feel, yeah.
-Yeah.
-'Cause, yeah, you would cry,
too, yeah if you --
-I don't [bleep] for a guy.
-What?
-I don't cry for the guys.
They cry for me,
I don't cry for them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're making me emotional.
You're making me emotional
right now
and I promised I wouldn't cry.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so happy you're here.
Congrats on every single little
new record breaking
smashing thing you keep doing.
Just don't stop. Don't stop.
Keep doing everything
you're doing.
I love you,
and please come back whenever.
Anitta, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Boys Don't Cry"
is available now.